IT PUTTING NEW TARIFFS ON
CHINESE GOODS IS CERTAINLY AN
AUCTION.
STOMACH STOMACH OPTION
>> Bret: TONIGHT,
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
BLOCKING HIM FROM TESTIFYING
ANYTHING ON THAT?
>> John: JUST GOT A STATEMENT
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE THAT
CONFIRMS THAT IT HAPPEN.
IT LET ME READ IT TO YOU.
IF THIS IS JUDD DEERE,
PRESS SECRETARY.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES ITS RESPONSE TO
COVID-19, INCLUDING SAFELY
OPENING UP AMERICAN AGAIN, AND
VACCINE DEVELOPMENT.
IT’S COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO YOU
HAVE THEM APPEAR AT
CONGRESSIONAL HEARINGS.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
CONGRESS TO OFFER TESTIMONY AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THIS IS BREAKING IN THE LAST FEW
MINUTES.
NOW SHE IS NOT GOING ANYWHERE
NEAR CAPITOL HILL, AT LEAST FOR
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE.